ANDREW WALES: Hey everyone.
Welcome to "Behind the Code."
Today, we're going to be
talking all about the Universal
Analytics Upgrade.
And to do that, we're going
to go right to the source.
We have Nick Mihailovski
joining us in the studio.
He's the product manager who's
been working on the Universal
Analytics Upgrade tool,
working tirelessly
to bring this upgrade
to all of our users.
So thanks for joining us, Nick.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Yeah,
thanks for having me here.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
Let's take a look at the agenda.
So Nick's going to
give us an overview
of what Universal Analytics is.
Second thing we'll
do is we'll go
through an overview
of the upgrade itself.
So what is it, why
we're doing it,
and just generally
what the steps are,
so you know a little
bit more about that.
Next, we'll cover
some common questions.
We've been getting
a lot of questions
from developers about how to
use our upgrade tool, what
that process looks like.
Also questions about
implementation and code,
so we'll go through
that as well.
And Nick will give us some
tips and great context
along the way.
And then at the end, we'll
give you some resources
that you can go to
after the video.
So if you have questions
or want to find out more
about a particular
topic of the upgrade,
you can check out the
resources and learn more.
Let's start at a
super high level.
For those who haven't
heard of it before,
what is Universal
Analytics, Nick?
Can you give us an overview?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI:
That's a great question.
Universal Analytics
is huge, right?
It's universal.
ANDREW WALES: Right.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: So let
me try to contain it down
into something really basic.
So in the past,
Google Analytics has
been about tracking
websites and web pages.
So over the past 15
years, we've seen
a huge increase in mobile
content consumption,
consumption across tablets, and
even content being distributed
across many other factors,
like kiosk, game consoles.
And so what we saw is the need
to create new infrastructure
within Google
Analytics that allows
us to track user behavior
across all of these devices.
So we launched last
year Universal Analytics
as a set of features
and libraries,
as well as infrastructure,
to allow us to now enable
businesses to measure how users
interact with their business
across all these
different devices.
ANDREW WALES: So
it's a collection.
You'd say it's some
infrastructure changes.
It's also new reports and
new features, and also
new libraries, all
bundled together.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Correct.
All bundled together.
And what really it is
is a platform for us
to add additional functionality
and features to really help
users better understand
how-- or help customers,
help them understand how
users are interacting
with their business across all
these different environments.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
OK.
So let's talk about
the upgrade then.
So why are we doing an upgrade?
What is it?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI:
That's a good question.
When we launched
Universal Analytics,
we required users
to create brand
new properties,
or tracking units.
And so all of the historical
data that they had
was still being processed
by classic Analytics,
and only new
properties were being
processed by
Universal Analytics.
So what the upgrade
allows people to do
is to actually upgrade their
classic Analytics accounts
into Universal
Analytics accounts.
And the features are
fantastic, because now you
have the ability to get all
the power of the new Universal
Analytics while maintaining
all your historical data.
So you can still do
year over year trends,
month over month trends,
pre and post the upgrade.
But you can also take advantage
of all the brand new features.
ANDREW WALES: So it's going to
be seamless, then, in Reports,
right?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Exactly.
ANDREW WALES: Awesome.
Awesome.
How would one upgrade?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI:
Well, we try to make
it as simple as possible.
And we boil it down
into two easy steps.
The first step is you actually
have to transfer processing
from your classic Analytics
to Universal Analytics.
And that's done through a tool.
The second step is to
actually retag or reimplement
the tracking code to go from
the classic tracking library
to the new Universal
Analytics library.
Now the second step is optional,
but it's highly recommended.
ANDREW WALES: So you don't
have to change your code,
but we recommend that you do.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: You
don't have to change it,
but we recommend you do.
ANDREW WALES: And maybe
we'll talk a little bit more
about that later
when we talk more
about the
implementation of code.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Sure.
Yeah.
ANDREW WALES: Now one other
thing that I wanted to ask you,
because I've gotten a bunch
of questions on this--
is there anybody who shouldn't
be upgrading right now?
Because a lot of people watching
this might have the question,
should I upgrade
or should I wait?
Is there anything
people should know?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI:
It's a great question.
So today there's many
features in Google Analytics--
the DoubleClick
integration features,
the deal with Remarketing,
DoubleClick for Advertisers.
The features that uses
the dc.js tracking code,
these features we're
still working on
to support them in
Universal Analytics.
So if you are using
any of these features,
you should wait just
a little bit longer
until we have full support
for all the features.
So if you're using
those, you shouldn't
use the upgrade today.
The other set of users who
shouldn't do this upgrade
is if you're not familiar
with how you've implemented
to the tracking code, make sure
you go to somebody who is more
familiar-- and make
sure that there's
no issues with your
implementation that will break.
So you want to make sure
you spend the time learning
about what this upgrade is and
the implications it could have.
Again, there's many people
using Google Analytics.
And a lot of them use it
in very creative ways.
And so if you are using
it in a creative way,
you want to make sure that you
know all the caveats involved
to make sure that your upgrade
is as seamless as possible,
and there's no risk of
data quality issues.
ANDREW WALES: So for example,
if you did a really custom
implementation with
ga.js on your website,
you're definitely one of the
people who we would suggest
would spend a little time
upfront to figure out
if anything is going to
break when you update.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Absolutely.
ANDREW WALES: So let's talk
about the upgrade tool.
Because you mentioned there
were two steps, right?
You're going to transfer
your property using a tool.
And then you can
optionally update the code.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Yeah.
ANDREW WALES: So this
would be step one,
using the upgrade tool.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Correct.
ANDREW WALES: What
is the update tool?
What do you do?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI:
Well, the upgrade tool
starts with an Admin
UI in Google Analytics.
ANDREW WALES: I think
I have screenshot.
So let me show it.
And then you can give us a--
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Yeah.
Fantastic.
So the upgrade tool allows
you to come into the Admin UI.
There's a new section for
upgrading Universe Analytics
Upgrade under each property.
So this happens at
the property level.
So if you look at
a property column,
you'll see a new
tab for the upgrade.
And when you click
on that, you'll
actually be able to go and
get to a page that takes you
through a series of steps
to transfer processing
from classic to
Universal Analytics.
So what you do is you
come into the tool.
You accept it.
You look through
the information.
Read all the documentation.
When you're ready, you
click to next stage.
You get a dialog sharing kind
of all the little caveats
and details.
And once you've agreed
and you confirm,
we actually schedule your
property to be transferred.
Now the transfer actually
takes between 24 and 48 hours.
And so you can
actually come back--
you'll see a little
state changed.
This says transfer in progress.
And actually, under the tab for
Universal Analytics Upgrade,
it'll say transfer in progress.
So you could always revisit
to see where you are
and what stage you're at.
Once we've finally
transferred after that time,
then it'll be saying
transfer complete.
And so that means once
the transfer is done,
you've completed step one
of the upgrade process.
ANDREW WALES: I click
the Transfer button.
I'm going to wait
24 to 48 hours.
Check my account.
And it's going to
give me a notice that
says it's done, right?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI:
It's that easy.
ANDREW WALES: That easy.
Cool.
So during that time,
can I still send data?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: You can
continue to send data.
But during the
time, you should not
retag to the new tracking code.
You need to make sure that
you complete step one, which
is the transfer
processing, before you move
to step two, which
is the actually
reimplementation
of tracking code.
ANDREW WALES: Otherwise?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: If
you don't do that,
it could lead to
data quality issues.
ANDREW WALES: So transfer,
wait until we confirm
it's been done in your
account, and then you
can change your code if
you want to in step two.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Exactly.
ANDREW WALES: So I've
gotten this question
from a number of users
who don't actually
see the upgrade tool
in their account.
Is there any reason
why someone out there
today would not see
the upgrade tool?
And how do they get
to see it, I guess.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: It's great.
So we whitelisted or
enabled this upgrade tool
for pretty much all of
the different accounts
and the properties within.
The only properties and accounts
we haven't enabled it for
is for properties
or profiles that
are using any of our DoubleClick
integration features.
For example, Remarketing or
DoubleClick for Advertisers.
If anybody's enabled
these features,
we've explicitly not
enabled this tool
for any of the profiles
within their account.
And the reason why
is that we want
to be extra careful because
we don't have full feature
support for these features
in Universal Analytics.
We're still working on them.
ANDREW WALES: Like Remarketing
and DoubleClick stuff.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Exactly.
Right.
Because we don't have the
full feature support for that.
We don't want to have
somebody accidentally upgrade
their account to something
that they can't use.
So for those properties, if
you don't see this today,
don't worry.
We're just ensuring
that there will
be no issues when we actually
do enable it for them.
ANDREW WALES: Got it.
And for accounts that
have a lot of users,
how do you know if somebody
else may have already upgraded
your property?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI:
What you can do
is always come into
the Property column.
And you'll look at the
Universal Analytics Upgrade tab.
And you'll always get
the status of where
you are, whether the transfer
is in progress, or if it hasn't
been done, or if it's complete.
ANDREW WALES: So it's
in the Admin section.
Look at the Property column,
Universal Analytics Upgrade
tab.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Exactly.
Yeah.
ANDREW WALES: So now
let's talk about step two
of the upgrade process, which
is actually updating your code.
So you mentioned that
updating the code
is actually optional, right?
Step one, transfer
your property.
But step two is optional.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Right.
ANDREW WALES: Why wouldn't
you update your code?
Or what do you get from
updating your code?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Right.
In Universal Analytics, when
we launched that, we also
announced a new
tracking code that
works with Universal
Analytics, analytics.js.
ANDREW WALES: For web.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: For web, yes.
And so the analytics.js
library is a lot more flexible
for developers.
So if you are
customizing the code,
it's a lot easier to customize.
And there's a lot more
functionality built
to simplify the customization.
So customization is a big thing.
The second part of it
is for large websites.
For example, with the
new tracking code,
we only use one cookie.
The old tracking code,
we used five cookies.
And so because cookies are sent
with all the different requests
on the page, you actually can
reduce a significant amount
of bandwidth for
large sites as well.
And finally, I think the
most important reason
is that we have a
bunch of new features
we're working on with
Universal Analytics.
We've announced
some, like User-ID.
These type of features will
only work with the new tracking
code.
And increasingly, we've
kind of have a team mandate
that all new features are built
only using Universal Analytics.
So increasingly, we can't
talk about them here,
but we are working on many
new features that will only
be supported by the new
Analytics.js tracking library.
ANDREW WALES: So
if you want access
to the latest and
greatest stuff,
use Analytics.js and
upgrade your code.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Right.
ANDREW WALES: Can you give us
just an overview of the changes
that you would need
to make as a developer
if you kind of had a simple
site and a simple implementation
of ga.js.
What would you need to do
to get to Analytics.js?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Well,
the basic implementation
for Google Analytics
on a website
is to put a piece of JavaScript
on all the pages of your site.
So that piece of JavaScript
has changed with Analytics.js.
So at minimum, you'd have to go
through all the different pages
of your site and implement
the new tracking code.
Replace the old
one with the new.
Now for people who are
doing more sophisticated
integrations-- they have event
tracking, social interactions,
e-commerce-- the actual tracking
interface, the actual methods
that you use on the
tracking code, have changed.
So what you'll need to do
is update all the places
where you're calling the old
library with the new methods
that are corresponding
to the new library.
ANDREW WALES: Got it.
So for some people
with big sites,
this is actually a pretty
sizable amount of work, right?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Yeah.
ANDREW WALES: Do they need to
update everything all at once?
Could you have on a
page some old ga.js code
and some new analytics.js code?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Well,
that's a great question.
So we've designed these
libraries to work together,
but there are some caveats.
So for a given
page, the tracking
works at a property ID.
So this UA number, UAXXX-Y. And
so for one of those properties,
you can only use one tracking
mechanism on a given page.
So either using analytics.js
or ga.js for a given page.
Now across different pages, we
have made these libraries work
together.
So you can have the
old tracking ga.js
code on 50% of pages
for one property.
And for the other 50%, you could
have the new one, analytics.js,
for the same property.
So the problem
really arises when
you actually, for the same
property, on the same page,
use different libraries.
ANDREW WALES: So for those
who are planning on retagging,
you could plan to kind of
break it up into chunks.
I'm going to retag
25% of my pages
with analytics.js and
so forth and so on.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Exactly.
Right.
ANDREW WALES: The
problem comes when
you try to get down
on the page level
and say, some of the stuff
is going to be analytics.js
on this page, the rest is ga.js.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Correct.
ANDREW WALES: That's not good.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Right.
Exactly, yeah.
And that's for a given property.
Now of course, there's always
the sophisticated users
who are using
multiple properties
on the same page for rollup
reporting or something
like this.
So if you have multiple
properties on the same page,
you can use ga.js for one of
the properties and analytics.js
for the other property.
The problem arises when it's the
same property on the same page
with two different
tracking codes.
ANDREW WALES: Is there
any reason to dual tag
at this point?
We have the upgrade tools.
So is there any reason
that you'd want to dual tag
your site completely with the
old code and the new code?
Or is it just time to
switch over completely?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: So dual
tagging, what a lot of people
do is they'll have the old
legacy ga.js across their site.
And then they'll create a new
Universal Analytics property.
And then they'll
implement analytics.js
with the new one
across their site.
So you're tagging
with two properties
because we didn't have this
upgrade tool in the past.
Now when people compare
the data between the two,
they're always going
to see a difference
because the actual sequence of
when the actual requests are
sent, the hits are sent to
Google Analytics, differ.
So we'll always never
see a difference.
So what we recommend for all
users, now we have the upgrade,
is to actually go
through the upgrade.
Don't dual tag.
Don't create a new Universe
Analytics property.
Rather, convert your existing
one to Universal Analytics.
And that ensures that the
data is the most consistent.
You have the historical data.
And then make sure that you
don't have these kind of deltas
between the two tracking
codes because they're
firing at a different
rate in the browser.
ANDREW WALES: That makes sense.
So for those people who are
going to put this off-- which
I don't hold it against
them for putting it off.
What happens if they
do nothing right now?
So you have ga.js
on your website.
It's been working fine.
Let's say you transfer
your property over,
but you don't actually
upgrade your code.
What happens then?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: So
once you've transferred
to Universe Analytics,
you could still
send the data from the
old tracking library.
That will continue to work.
Over time, you'll see
that more features are
added to the
analytics.js library,
so you won't get to
take advantage of them.
But we'll still collect the
old data and process that.
And we can look a little bit
into the timeline, kind of talk
about how this will work
out in the long term.
ANDREW WALES: Let's move.
So we just talked about websites
and code implementation issues
there.
Let's move to mobile apps.
I think the users out there
who are using SDK version
1.0, that's really the library
that we're talking about.
Those are the
people who are going
to be upgrading, because
version 2.0 or higher
are already sending hits
to Universal Analytics.
So for those users
using version 1.0,
what does the upgrade
process look like for them?
Is it kind of the
same thing as web?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: It's
similar, but it's different.
So it's important for mobile
users to pay attention.
Step one of transferring from
classic to Universal Analytics
continues to work.
When you do the
transfer, you might
see some small
differences in the way
the sessions are calculated.
You might have a lower
number of visits to the site.
But there's no way around this.
This is just the way
that we're changing
on how sessions are calculated
between the old classic
and then to the new
Universal Analytics.
So you might see
a slight decrease
in the number of visits
in your reporting profile.
And that's for
transferring on step one.
Once you complete
step one, you'll
continue to actually
view your data
in Google Analytics
as a web profile.
Now when we introduced
app tracking last year,
we introduced a
brand new data model.
New app tracking
Google Analytics.
It was actually really based
on Universal Analytics,
but it also came with a new
app tracking data model.
Now it's all around
screen views.
And in metrics, that made
sense for applications.
We also created a whole new set
of UI reports specific to apps.
Now those work with
SDK 2.0 plus versions,
but they don't work with v1.
It's still using the
old page view tracking.
So if you are using v1, you
have a couple of options.
One is to continue
using the v1 SDK
and viewing your
reports in web profiles.
It's the standard web profile.
The second option you have is
you can actually upgrade to v2,
change all your code from
page tracking to app tracking.
But today, if you view
that in Analytics,
you'll actually have to
create a new app profile.
And all your data will
be in the app profile.
So the issue it becomes is
that now all the new data
is in an app profile,
whereas all the old data is
in a web profile.
And so the challenge with
that is that you actually
can't trend data over
time because they're
in different profiles.
So it leads to some
reporting challenges.
ANDREW WALES: Got it.
So if you want continuity
between the data,
you would complete step
one, transfer your property.
Don't upgrade your code.
Still use SDK v1, and keep
sending your hits there.
And that will work fine, and
everything will be continuous,
just like you'd expect.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Correct.
ANDREW WALES: If you wanted to
get access to the new reporting
features for apps,
all the new stuff
that we've launched
for apps, you'd
actually have to create a new
app profile or a new app view.
And then upgrade your code
and send your data to that.
And that causes the
break in continuity.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Correct.
ANDREW WALES: So it's
a bit of a trade-off.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: It's a bit
of a trade-off right now.
This is something
that we're working on.
So by all means, there's
no rush to actually retag
to version 2.0.
But we do recommend at
least looking at step
one to transfer from classic to
Universal Analytics processing.
ANDREW WALES: So step
one, everybody can do it.
It's no problem.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Everybody
can do that today.
It's the retagging where
there's a couple considerations.
ANDREW WALES: So we've
covered step one and step
two of the upgrade process.
I definitely wanted to ask
you more about the timeline,
because I'm sure people are
going to be wondering when they
need to actually do this stuff,
and what we're doing on our end
as well.
So we've got four
phases in this timeline.
This is actually unique because
we published our timeline.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Right.
Usually, we never
publish timelines.
So this something--
ANDREW WALES: Being transparent.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI:
Pretty excited that-- we
try to be as
transparent as possible.
ANDREW WALES: So
we got four phases.
We're in the first phase, right?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Correct.
ANDREW WALES: Can you walk us
through where we are right now
and where we're going?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: So
phase one was really
the launch and announcement
that we can actually
do this upgrade.
Our goal at the
end of the day is
to transfer 100% of properties
from classic to Universal
Analytics, as well
as get everybody
to upgrade and to start only
building features on Universal
Analytics.
So we announced the
upgrade so people
can migrate from the
classic to Universal
Analytics a couple
of months ago.
So that's where we are.
Phase two is that we realized
many people won't actually
go through this step
one, transferring.
So what we plan
to do is to start
auto-transferring
properties from classic
to Universal Analytics.
So what that means
is instead of the end
users going into the
interface and Admin Tool
and transferring, we'll
manually go in and set
that bit for them.
And then over time,
their stuff will
be transferred on
the processing side.
ANDREW WALES: So when
does that happen?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI:
So we've started
with some test accounts.
We'll start ramping up probably
within the next month or so.
To start with small
accounts-- accounts
that have a much lower risk
of having data quality issues.
And then over time, as we
get full feature parity,
we'll then start ramping
that up to account the larger
accounts, accounts
with integrations,
with AdSense, AdWords,
the DoubleClick.
And finally, the premium
clients will be last in that.
Now phase three is once we
have full feature support.
So again, we're missing
some DoubleClick features.
Today, Universal Analytics
is still in beta.
And it doesn't have some
of the premium SLAs.
So our goal is to have one
large announcement that actually
takes the Universal Analytics
out of beta, has 100%
feature support, full
SLA, and the goal
is to do that early next year.
So once we do that
phase three, we'll
be ramping up this
auto-transferring
of properties much more.
We'll be doing more at a time.
Our final end goal, once we've
reached 100% of properties
transferred to
Universal Analytics,
is to then enter phase four,
which Universal Analytics
becomes the default
of Google Analytics.
They become the same thing.
At that point, we will actually
announce the deprecation
of the old tracking code, ga.js,
as well some of the features
and custom variables.
And so the announcement
of the deprecation
really means we'll continue to
accept and process the data,
but we'll do so for a
minimum of two years.
So after two years,
we'll revisit
whether we want to
continue doing that,
or we want to make sure
that everybody upgrades
to the new tracking code.
ANDREW WALES: Got it.
So auto-transferring.
Nobody's going to be
auto-transferred who
is using a feature that we
don't yet support, right?
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Correct.
ANDREW WALES: We're waiting
until we have support,
and then we'll start
moving those accounts.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Right.
A lot of people had
concern about that.
We're completely taking
that into account.
We're being very cautious
on who we transfer.
And only once we have full
feature support and everything
works well, will we then
start doing it more broadly.
ANDREW WALES: And it
sounds like from what
you were saying, when
we get to phase four
and we announce the
deprecation of ga.js,
there's going to be
a minimum two years.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Correct.
ANDREW WALES: So
from today, you've
got two years plus
of using ga.js.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI:
Of using ga.js.
ANDREW WALES: And
we'll support it.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: We'll
continue to support it.
There is kind of a nuance there.
Some of the more
power users are using
a feature called
Custom Variables.
Custom Variables was
available in ga.js.
In analytics.js, we
have something new
called Custom Dimensions.
And there is really no
migration between the two.
That being said, if you are
sending Custom Variables
and you do transfer processing
to Universe Analytics,
we'll continue to process
the Custom Variables
in Universal Analytics
as a legacy feature.
ANDREW WALES: But you
wouldn't get access
to Customer Dimensions unless
you upgraded your code.
NICK MIHAILOVSKI: Unless
you upgraded the code.
ANDREW WALES:
Well, we've covered
step one and two of the upgrade,
as well as the timeline.
I just wanted to quick give
everyone some resources
that you can go to after
watching this video.
So if you want to learn
more about how to upgrade,
we have this whole upgrade
center that we published.
It's at
developers.google.com/analytics/upgrade.
You can go there, and it
covers migration paths
for whatever library
you're using.
We've documented how
to upgrade from there.
So definitely check that out.
If you have any other
questions on top of that,
we have a UA upgrade forum
that you can check out.
And the link is
here on this slide.
And as I mentioned
at the beginning,
we're also going to be doing
a follow-up Q&A session.
So if you have any questions
that we didn't cover today,
and I'm sure there
are a bunch out there,
definitely post your questions
for our Google Moderator.
And we should have a link
to that below this video.
So definitely do that.
And we'll be back in about
a month, give or take.
And we'll answer those
questions and hopefully
some more as well.
Thanks for joining us.
This has been "Behind the
Code," all about the Universal
Analytics Upgrade.
Check us out on G+ as well.
Feel free, as I said,
to check out our Upgrade
Center as well if you
want to learn more.
We'll catch you next time.